[Musik]
[Applaus]
herzlich willkommen zum sport report dem
sport podcast des österreichischen
bundesheers heute zu gast
das heißt ich brauche auch meine
monatskarte heute nicht denn ich werde
interviewt von paul leitenmüller von
pinien leaders netzwerk herzlich
willkommen und herzlich willkommen
da wusste ich heute ist selber begrüßen
die war die ich freue mich wirklich sehr
dass wir heute hier diesen podcast aber
auch dieses video produzieren dürfen wir
soll es ein bisschen hinaus tragen dass
sport report ab sofort auch einem boot
kurs macht du bist der moderator
schlechthin ist vielleicht ganz kurz was
ist dann bei moderieren so cool ich bin
einfach wahnsinnig fasziniert davon mich
selbst zu hören aber zu reden und
einfach damit aus menschen was
herauszukitzeln eine botschaft zu
transportieren und ob das jetzt im
studio setting ist ob das im podcast ist
ob das für einen für ein videoformat ist
einfach mit persönlichkeiten eine
geschichte zu erzählen und da etwas
herauszukitzeln
ich liebe es also das ist das was mich
an moderieren einfach so passioniert
seit wann machst du das ich habe 2012
bin ich ein bisschen ins kalte wasser
geworfen worden vom orf und bin gebeten
worden dass ich einen behindertensport
format moderiert und von dort hat sich
da einfach schrittweise verschiedenste
formate geben und mittlerweile auch als
veranstaltungs moderator unterwegs und
wie gesagt das noch einfach so viel spaß
und zwar sich ja nicht blöd sie neben
der ganzen schwimmer rey auch ein
käppchen und und was anderes zu tun
im leben einfach für mich eine schöne
abwechslung genommen wichtig auch für
meine entwicklung und gesagt ich weiß du
bist jetzt ja nicht nur moderator
sondern du bist spitzensport war das
heißt du bist leistungssportler aber es
fehlt dir deine linke hand das sieht man
plötzlich ganz so gut aber jetzt zuerst
ein bild gesehen rote kreuz mit einer
hand nach vorne schaut ihnen wie schräge
aus wie geht kragen mit einer hand die
meisten glauben immer dass man im kreis
erscheint das ist nicht so ist
vielleicht wenn man weiterhin hat und
dann habe ich versucht das zu machen
dass man sich ein bisschen schwieriger
tut mein vater war ich habe es nur eine
ich gelernt ich kenne es gar nicht
anders wenn ich menschen zwei filmen
sehe denke ich mir wie machen die das
wer wie geht das
ich habe das gar nicht vorstellen
gedanklich
im endeffekt ist das training sei es
geht darum die richtung zu halten
auszugleichen mit den körper gliedmassen
die man zur verfügung hat und das grauen
selbst kann ich nicht so gut dass ich
bin eher der brust und lagen schwimmer
das ist er dann meine spezialität aber
und das ist das was oftmals noch gar
nicht so präsent ist man kann mit einer
behinderung leistungssportler sein man
kann mit einer behinderung spitzensport
betreiben und das ist auch das was ich
mit meinem sport mit meiner stimme rey
dass im kreis schwimmen auch ein
bisschen zeigen möchte
und bis jetzt sieht man sie auch der
unter einem muskel wird das heißt wie
oft trainierst du wie geht das
also ich sage immer dass der körper das
ausgleichen muss was ihm sonst fehlen
würde der linke arbeitsweg und somit
gleich personen rechten bizeps und
trizeps aus ich trainiere sechs tage die
woche zweimal am tag manchmal dreimal am
tag oftmals eben mit zwei mal am tag im
wasser wenn nicht krafttraining
ausdauertraining also das volle programm
und widme mich dementsprechend auch als
profi in meinem sport anders geht das
auch gar nicht mehr also meine ganzen
konkurrenten sind alles vollprofi der
behindertensport hat sich enorm
entwickelt in den letzten jahren und
wenn man nicht dieses trainingspensum an
den tag gelegt hat man einfach kein land
vorne um irgendwie am podium zu stehen
und somit gehört das dazu
ich nehme das gerne an es ist nicht
einfach ist das anstrengend das ist hart
aber es ist der teil wo ich mich selbst
disziplinieren muss man einfach
regelmäßig brav zu sein und mein
training zu machen und die positiven
effekte sind dann bestimmte muskeln
regionen die dann ausgeprägter sind wie
ist das jetzt kann man sagen die
disziplin des sports ist mehr oder
weniger auch für ein wirtschaftliches
erfolgreiches leben ein vorbild gibt es
hier einen gleichklang absolut also ich
glaube dass wenn man die die tugenden
dass sport das nicht auch im
wirtschaftlichen leben einsatz wenn man
sie nicht in seinem persönlichen leben
hat eben disziplin zielgerichtet ehrgeiz
dass man dran bleibt das nicht aufhört
dass man sich nicht unterkriegen lassen
das sind alles dinge die ich im sport
gelernt habe die ich im sport
perfektionieren konnte und wie ich sehe
dass sie hoffentlich dann auch in einem
wirtschaftlichen leben zum erfolg
bringen werden aber wenn man sich
anschaut wer sind denn die erfolgreichen
menschen da sind dass menschen die
diszipliniert sein können sie zu sich
selbst am strengsten
sind die auch eine ein gewisses niveau
haben eine gewisse gut gesundheit an den
tag legen und ich glaube dass das
einfach das fundament die basis ist um
überhaupt egal in welchem lebensbereich
erfolg haben zu können also unsere
gesellschaft kann er sicher von sport
enorm viel profitieren
gibt es da auch etwas aus dem
spitzensport schwimmen wo du sagst das
hilft beim moderieren
dass ich mich selber mal zwei stunden
lang nicht höher das geht nach dem
ausgleich dass ich unter wasser einfach
irgendeine gedanken gehen aber nicht
meine stimme hören muss und sonst sich
zutrauen es gibt auch momente wo man von
neuen herausforderungen steht wettkampf
situationen in denen man so vielleicht
noch gar nicht war und trotzdem den
schlitz und machen trotzdem ins wasser
zu springen
trotzdem furchtlos und mutiges zu tun
das kann man mit moderieren schon
vergleichen wenn man auf neun bühnen
steht wenn man von neuen publikum sein
wird wenn man neue formate ausprobieren
muss aufgrund der pandemie zum beispiel
alles virtuell oder hybrid dass man sich
da traut mutig ist und einfach mal einen
schritt macht ein bisschen aus der
komfortzone heraus also dass sie sicher
etwas was ich aus dem schwimmsport mit
ins moderieren nehmen konnte paralympics
da bist du mit dabei
wie funktioniert das welche disziplinen
gibt es dort wer schwimmt miteinander
also im endeffekt kann man es
unterbrechen das was im olympischen
schwimm sport da ist gibt es so gut wie
gleich auch im paralympischen wir haben
ein bisschen andere disziplinen weil wir
einfach so viele behinderung klassen
haben das heißt wir können nicht jeden
bewerb in 14 behinderung klassen
durchführen deswegen ist das programm
ein bisschen gestraffter im endeffekt
geht es darum wer am schnellsten von a
nach b schwimmt und man ist so gruppiert
dass man gegen ähnliche behinderung
formen schwimmt das heißt ging menschen
die ähnlich eingeschränkt sind beim
schwimmen selbst das ist nie
hundertprozentig fair auch das ist eine
lektion fürs leben das leben jetzt nicht
so hundertprozentig fair aber muss auch
damit umgehen lernen und aus der
situation das beste machen und ich bin
zum beispiel in der kategorie 8
und das heißt ich bin eher am oberen
ende der behinderung schwere also eher
leichter behindert und dann gibt es von
kategorie 1 bis kategorie 14 eben
verschiedene studierenden stufen und
schattierungen je nach
behinderung also ganz ganz komplex
wichtig ist wer als erster anschlägt
gewonnen das ist ja du bist ein
burgenländer und du bist ich habe sie im
vorgespräch gehört fast 30 irgendwann
einmal wird das ende im behindertensport
foto mit schwimm bedacht aber jetzt 1
wählen bist du jetzt noch in der
leistungsklasse da voll drinnen wie
funktioniert das vom wo kommst du her wo
bist du aufgewachsen
was steht hinter der person andreas ohne
ja also ursprünglich kommen meine eltern
aus rumänien sind nach österreich
geflüchtet und ich bin eine zweite liga
ist reich geboren war dann drei jahre
lang dort und als wir nach nach wien
gezogen und habe dann in wien den
großteil meiner meiner kindheit
verbracht und dann wieder zurück nach
nieder sagt bin ich überall und
nirgendwo ich selbst dadurch dass ich in
österreich geboren wurde und
aufgewachsen bin habe mich immer schon
als als österreicher gesehen mit
rumänischen wurzeln in 2015 auch
staatsbürger geworden damit ich dann
2005 studium 2005 staatsbürger geworden
damit ich dann auch meine ganzen erfolge
für österreich schwimmen konnte im
endeffekt war der große einschnitt der
unfall derart im endeffekt das leben
meiner familie in zwei teile geteilt
nämlich vor dem unfall nach dem unfall
und der war 1998 da war meine eltern
gerade sieben jahre in österreich das
war auch der grund warum ich angefangen
habe mit dem sport nach dem unfall wo
ich eigentlich sterben hätte müssen dass
es gibt keinen grund warum ich heute
überhaupt noch da bin und das führt mich
auch dazu dass ich so dankbar bin dass
sich die dinge mit mit freude sehe und
einfach alles was ich tun darf auch
jetzt als spitzensportler beim
bundesheer als herr sportlers als
privileg sehe im endeffekt der unfall
hat erst dazu geführt dass sich diese
diese gedankenwelt in mir reifen lassen
konnte und bin dann schrittweise in den
sport geführt worden über therapien über
verschiedenste kleinere wettkämpfe war
mit zwölf staatsmeister 2008 zum ersten
mal in peking bei den paralympics dabei
da ist der traum aufgekommen
vielleicht wird das auch gehen dass ich
als einarmiger aus einer
einwandererfamilie in einem land das mit
film sport jetzt nicht so unbedingt als
nation aufgewachsen ist dass ich
trotzdem schaffen am podium zu stehen
es war der große traum ich wollte dafür
hart arbeiten dass ich dann gemacht in
london hat es knapp nicht gereicht da
haben 26 hundertstel gefehlt und gott
sei dank denn in rio de janeiro an
diesen traum erfüllen können und das
bild das wir hinter uns sehen für die
die uns zu schauen das ist unmittelbar
nach dem anschlag für die bronze
medaille bei den paralympics dann
entstanden bin wie gesagt bald 30 im
behindertensport es sicherer große
vorteil dass man ein paar jährchen
länger im spitzensport aktiv sein kann
aber ich mache mir da noch keine
gedanken wären es bringt eine freude
wo nimmst du denn her gibt es zeiten wo
du sagst es fehlt mir eine hand und da
bist du so richtig auch deprimiert wo du
sagst oder ist das vorbei hast du das
weg geehrt wird hast du das gelernt zu
sagen ich bin so wie ich bin und ich bin
stolz darauf dass ich so bin wie ich bin
oder gibt es zeiten wo du sagst
eigentlich weiß ich ich habe hier ein
defizit dieser gedanken hatte ich nie
weil ich einfach so jung war ich war
sechs jahre wie der unfall passiert ist
das heißt ich kenne es eigentlich gar
nicht mehr anders ich habe kaum
erinnerungen wie es ist zwei arme zu
haben das heißt ich bin so aufgewachsen
für mich existiere ich auch in meinem
kopf nur so ich träume als einarmiger
mich selbst das heißt ich kenne das gar
nicht mehr
ich verstehe schon dass menschen die
später im leben einen unfall haben mit
diesen gedanken konfrontiert sind und da
möchte ich auch helfen und zeigen dass
behinderung jetzt nicht unbedingt ein
defizit ist dass man auch mit der
behinderung seine träume erfüllen kann
erfolgreich sein kann
eine mission eine vision haben kann und
einfach impact haben kann in unserer
gesellschaft in unserer welt und da ist
der sport natürlich eine super sache
weil es auffällt man sieht dass ich nur
einen arm habe aber man sieht dann halt
auch was ich mit diesem einen abend
alles geschafft habe und das ist so ein
bisschen die botschaft ich sowohl für
menschen mit behinderung habe aber auch
für menschen ohne behinderung
die sich vielleicht ein schwenken lassen
von von dingen die im leben einmal
passiert sind
von von krankheiten verlust davon gingen
auf die wir im endeffekt keine kontrolle
haben auf die wir keinen einfluss haben
und das ist auch das was ich relativ
früh gelernt habe ich verstanden habe
den unfall rückgängig machen kann nicht
gar nicht möchte ich auch nicht aber was
ich sehr wohl beeinflussen kann ist
meine reaktion auf den unfall wirklich
damit möchte ich mich in die opferrolle
spielen möchte ich leiden möchte ich das
gefühl haben ich habe etwas verloren
oder nämlich die dinge so an wie sie
sind macht das beste draus und schlage
einen neuen lebensweg ein der für mich
so toll ist dass ich gar keinen zweiten
haben wir haben möchte auch wenn ich
weiß das klingt makaber es klingt blöd
man kann es vielleicht gar nicht als
außenstehender verstehen aber für mich
ist das das schönste leben das sich
haben kann das was sich derzeit als
spitzensportler moderator und eben
speaker lebe was ich die welt bereisen
kann meine eigenen grenzen ausloten kann
und eben im wissen dass sich menschen
etwas mitgeben kann das auch wirklich
bedeutung hat ich glaube diese positive
einstellung ist wirklich es seien
beispielhaft es gibt ja so viele leute
die gerade jetzt in dieser partie nie
zeit sich zu tode fürchten und sagen wie
schrecklich ist alles aber in
wirklichkeit wenn du nicht wirklich
erkrankt bis dann corona ist es ja
eigentlich so dass man das ist eine in
seinem kopf ganz gut verarbeiten könnte
mit positiven gedanken da bist du
wirklich ein leuchtendes beispiel ich
gratuliere herzlich dazu ein hehres
sport s sport 450 spitzensportler gibt's
dort du bist einer davon
wie geht es dazu was heißt das will ich
unterstützung bekommt unser also 2016
nach rio ist das zentrum für uns
behindertensportler und
behindertensportlerin geöffnet worden
mittlerweile sind wir 20 von diesen 450
und im endeffekt ist das die grundlage
dass man überhaupt als profi seinen
sport betreiben kann
das wäre sonst den behindertensport
nicht so leicht möglich weil einfach die
situation die einnahmen nicht so sind im
olympischen sport und im endeffekt also
die grundlage als herr sportler was mir
auch enormen gefallen hat und was sich
als enorm wichtig erachte ist dass das
bundesheer uns wirklich auf augenhöhe
kommuniziert uns auf augenhöhe
unterstützt
alle zugänge zur infrastruktur sind
genauso da wie auch für unsere
olympischen kolleginnen und kollegen
also dass einfach kein unterschied
gemacht wird und das ist enorm wichtig
das ist ein starkes gesellschaftliches
zeichen und zeigt auch dass das
bundesheer sich als der größte förderer
im sport versteht und diese rolle auch
aktiv an nimmt in dem eben auch nicht
nur die olympiasiegerinnen und
olympiasieger von morgen und von heute
im bundesheer sind sondern auch die
paralympics siegerinnen und paralympics
sieger von morgen und von heute
mit dabei sind und das ist es eine mega
tolle sache und weil du vorher eben
diese gedankenwelt auch angesprochen
hast wie wir uns selber einschränken
ich glaube auch dass man eben die
geschichten dieser athletinnen und
athleten kommuniziert dass man damit
auch genau das bewirken kann und podcast
format mit dem videoformat ist einfach
optimal damit man sehen kann was ist
denn hinter dem menschen hinter dem
spitzensportler alles da was hat er
dafür fahren gemacht was hatte alles
gelernt und was kann man vielleicht als
außenstehender als interessierter
mitnehmen und da vielleicht auch gar
nicht nur die pandemie sondern allgemein
mit schwierigen umständen mit
herausforderungen wie kann man vom
spitzensportler und von der
spitzensportlerin lernen und für das
eigene leben etwas mitnehmen
du bist ein sehr gläubiger mensch aber
in der vorbereitung mitgenommen und das
ist nicht deswegen weil du sagst du hast
dich bedankt dafür dass du deinen unfall
überlebt hast sondern das ist eine
essenz wo du sagst wie schaut es da aus
wie wie geht's dir mit dem glauben und
warum der christliche glaube ich bin ein
sehr gläubiger mensch ist für mich ein
wichtiger bestandteil meines lebens ich
bin in einem christlichen haushalt
aufgewachsen meine eltern haben immer
wert darauf gelegt dass ich mich selber
für ihren glauben entscheide und einfach
die die freiheit habe mich zu
entscheiden
ich habe durch den unfall relativ
schnell wir fragen gestellt die man sich
vielleicht das später im leben stellen
würde oder das als kind oder
jugendlicher gar nicht sich damit
auseinandersetzt warum bin ich hier
was ist der sinn und zweck wenn es so
schnell vorbei gehen kann
was hat das ganze für für einen sinn und
ich habe den unfall als geschenk
angefangen zu sehen als als tür geöffnet
wurde für mich ich weiß das klingt
schwer verständlich ich bin dankbar für
den unfall ich bin dankbar dass ich
überlebt habe aber auch dankbar dass ich
jetzt mit seiner behinderung durchs
leben gehen kann weil ich einfach
dadurch so viel neues kennenlernen
konnte im in meinem glaubensleben auch
gefestigt werden konnte und was mich
immer schon bewegt hat und uns sehr
fasziniert das war diese hoffnung freude
und und diese dieser optimismus den der
glaube meinen eltern ausgelöst hatte ich
erinnere mich dass mein vater mir
erzählt hat nach dem unfall
er war schwer verletzt ich hatte eben
die behinderung meiner mutter was schwer
verletzt mein großvater ist dann leider
verstorben und er hat mir dann erzählt
dass er aus dem koma aufgewacht ist und
sie haben erzählt was passiert ist
er hat angefangen zu weinen ich bin
damals sechsjähriger zu ihm hingegangen
und gesagt papa warum weinst und sagt na
schaut dir fehlt dann aber mir geht es
nicht gut mama geht es nicht gut
europa geht es auch nicht gut wie soll
ich nicht weinen und ich hab dann als
kind gesagt ich bekomme meine puppen
hand und alles wird gut und das ist
anscheinend in diesem in diesem
optimismus umfeld in mir so gereift dass
alles immer gut wird es gibt immer eine
lösung es gibt immer eine möglichkeit
und das hat mich enorm geprägt dass sie
meinem glaubensleben auch so ausleben zu
können habe in vielen herausforderungen
und einfach die stärke gehabt und war
für mich einfach eine ähnlich wichtige
stütze vielleicht noch ein paar private
fragen der antigone er wohnte derzeit in
der nähe von der südstadt damit ich dort
im herzzentrum mein training ja
tagtäglich absolvieren kann meine eltern
sind in deutsch wagram wohnhaft das
heißt wir sind gerade nordöstlich von
wien sozusagen zur ruhe gekommen und
aber wie gesagt ich bin ich sehe mich
als mensch der die welt als seine heimat
sieht und sich einfach dort wohlfühlt wo
die familie in der nähe ist und das
heißt wir wer ist dass ich alleine
allein es war genau die frage gibt es
schon
und mitten im leben geglaubt war das
sportlerleben ist ist ein ganz
besonderes und da ist die die
partnerwahl eine ganz ganz noch einmal
besonders wichtiger also noch nicht dass
du suchst noch so dass so ein tier ist
noch ich bin ich lasse mich finden sein
also ein aufruf wer jährige aber näher
kennengelernt hat darf sich hier heute
bei uns melden training habe ich gelesen
bis zu 18 trainingseinheiten in der
woche was heißt was wie geht das und das
setzt sich zusammen aus eben
schwimmtraining krafttraining
ausdauertraining bei den ganzen region
aktiven maßnahmen die man setzt das sind
dann leben sie noch im körper ja auch
belastungen sind ja auch
trainingseinheit nur zur physiotherapie
massagen stunden lang ist das tracking
was man alles macht stabil training also
das ist alles da hinein gerechnet und
ich habe das mal zusammengerechnet und
komme in den wirklich harten wochen auf
die 18 einheiten
also es ist beinahe der spitzensport man
muss sich seinen in seinem gesamten
alltag damit auseinandersetzen und hat
den kopf im endeffekt dann auch
permanent dabei wie komme ich da
nächsten einheit was muss ich schauen
dass das wirklich gute einheit wird das
sich wirklich die qualität hoch halte
also im endeffekt werden nicht vollgas
dabei ist hat keine chance
wie viel zeit nimmt die moderation
vorbereitung in anspruch für deine
sendungen
es kommt natürlich auf das projekt an
das kommt darauf an ob ich meine
interviewpartner und interviewpartnerin
schon länger kenne weil man eben
sportlerkarriere parallel sozusagen
geführt hat aber es ist etwas was
wirklich zeit in anspruch nimmt aber es
macht nicht viel spaß und es ist für
mich einfach eine willkommene
abwechslung ist etwas wo ich nicht
körperlich angestrengt bin sondern
einfach in der erholungszeit daheim mich
wirklich einmal anderen dingen widmen
kann kopf abschalten kann indem ich mich
eben vorbereitet
also da kommt wie gesagt je nachdem wie
sich was zusammen aber für mich einfach
ein enorm wichtiger bestandteil auch
schon von meinem alltag würden einfach
ein paar sachen denken wie denn wie du
denkst zum thema bewältigung dieser
pandemie was heißt das für uns wie geht
man damit um wir wussten so alles
schützen selbstverständlich aber wir
haben auch gewisse dinge gelernt
zum stichwort home office
digitalisierung es gibt einfach dinge
die lernt man aus solchen krisen wie
siehst du das
ich versuche in allen dingen das
positive zu sehen
ich glaube dass man auch in einer
pandemie etwas positives sehen kann
zumindest im privaten
aber auch als gesellschaft haben wir
vieles gelernt und vieles mitgenommen
das heißt jetzt nicht dass die pandemie
etwas gutes ist das möchte ich nicht
sagen also habe ich dann nicht
missverstehen wir hoffen auch dass es
bald vorbei ist aber ich hoffe dass wir
trotzdem dinge die wir als gesellschaft
gelernt haben mitnehmen in die zukunft
zum beispiel dass wir uns anpassen
mussten und dinge die vielleicht vorher
schleppend voran gegangen sind weil es
ja immer schon so war das man halt dinge
so gemacht hat waren plötzlich notwendig
prozesse zu digitalisieren plötzlich
notwendig dass man ausgestattet ist und
auch flexibler arbeiten zu können ich
glaube das wird als gesellschaft enorm
profitieren können wenn wir diese dinge
mitnehmen als mensch mit behinderung zum
beispiel sehe ich schon dass der ganze
zwang zum home office für viele auch
eine möglichkeit war die vorher
eingeschränkt waren einen arbeitsplatz
zu erreichen und plötzlich konnten sie
aber digital teilhaben und inklusion
konnte dadurch sehr wohl beschleunigt
werden natürlich gibt es auch da
negative seiten und die muss man schauen
dass man die so klein wie möglich hält
aber als gesellschaft habe da eine
enorme chance auch als sportlerin und
sportler mussten wir uns plötzlich
anpassen mussten plötzlich reagieren
also wir haben sich enorm viel gelernt
in der flexibilität in der art und weise
wie wir planen wie wir reagieren können
gegensteuern also ganz ganz viele dinge
die man mitnehmen konnte wo ich hoffe
dass die dann wirklich auch nachhaltig
festgesetzt bleiben und nicht wieder
weggehen auch das dass wir uns als staat
unsere strukturen es so denken müssen
dass sie auch in einer krise
funktionieren dass wir bereit sein
müssen
in krisensituationen trotzdem leistung
abzurufen und nicht zu sagen dass super
summer krise jetzt lassen wir alles
liegen dass das können wir nicht
plötzlich waren bereiche gefordert
unsere gesellschaft die die vorher
vielleicht auch nicht so ganz in der
öffentlichkeit standen und plötzlich
gibt es da wieder die aufmerksamkeit und
da auch bewegung voranzubringen
entwicklung voranzubringen also ich
glaube schon dass wir in zehn 15 20
jahren zurück schauen werden und sagen
werden ja da ist was losgetreten worden
dass unsere gesellschaft dann auch ins
positive verändert hat ich darf nochmals
kurz wächst unter behinderten
sportverband ist sie ein großes anliegen
den hast du auch gleich einiges zu
verdanken
kann man jetzt sagen
es gibt einen appell von dir wie mögen
den öl in österreich behinderte gesehen
werden nämlich nicht behindert richtig
ich denke dass man den menschen sehen
sollte dass man das sehen sollte was der
mensch kann und nicht das was er nicht
kann und wenn es etwas gibt was er nicht
kann und dass von einer barriere
hervorgerufen ist dann gehört diese
barriere eliminiert dann müssen wir
schauen dass diese barriere nicht mehr
da ist
oder sind auf der einen seite bauliche
barrieren aber auf der anderen seite
einfach diese berührungsängste diese
mentalen barrieren die einfach noch da
sind ja wie gehe ich mit einem menschen
mit behinderung um wien er ich mich ihm
was darf ich sagen was hab ich nichts
sagen
und meine antwort ist ganz normal so wie
mit jedem anderen menschen auch wenn
nicht was interessiert fragst du dir
dazu was antworten möchte wenn er nicht
antworten möchte dann ist es ein
absolutes recht ich bin dass ich als
schwimmer auch exponiert und habe in
schwimmbädern halt und wenn kinder neben
mir trainieren kommt halt immer die
frage dass der neue namen wie kannst du
überhaupt schwimmen ja und ich kann
natürlich beleidigt sein und sagen
wollte das schwimmen konzentrieren und
mich in ruhe lassen oder das salz
möglichkeit nutzen einen positiven
berührungspunkte zu schaffen um in
diesen kindern ein umdenken zu bewirken
und ihnen zu zeigen
ich habe zwar nur einen aber ich bin
positiv ich bin nett ich bin höflich ich
antworte ich gerne und ich find's super
schnell und da diese verbindungen her zu
schaffen ich glaube dass das auch
wirklich enorm viel bewirken kann ich
habe 2009 10 bei der weltmeisterschaft
einen schwimmer aus malaysia
kennengelernt der mir erzählt hat dass
er wahnsinnig fasziniert ist davon wie
ich schwimme und ich war dann halt
geschmeichelt aber nicht gut aber der
film ein anderer schwimmer viel besser
als ich und hat mir erzählt nach für ihn
ist es so besonders wenn er mich schämen
sieht weil das allererste schwimmerinnen
dass er jemals gesehen hat war mein
finale bei den paralympics 2008 in
peking und ihm fehlt auch der linke arm
sowie mir und das gemeinsam mit seinem
vater schaut und sein vater gesagt
siehst du diesen 16 jährigen jungen mann
aus österreich dem väter linke arm
genauso wie die lieber james wenn der
das kann dann kannst du das auch und
james hat mir erzählt dass das der tag
war als er selber schwimmer wurde oder
sich entschieden hat dass er schwimmen
möchte und elf jahre später sind wir
gemeinsam bei der weltmeisterschaft
gegeneinander geschwommen
und das war für mich so der beweis das
was wir als menschen mit behinderung tun
kann in unserer gesellschaft
etwas voranbringen das kann gesehen
werden und entweder eben hoffnung sein
für menschen mit behinderung beweis dass
es sehr wohl funktionieren kann aber
auch berührungspunkt für menschen ohne
behinderung damit sie ein umdenken
bewirken und wir als gesellschaft
weiterhin die inklusion vorantreiben
können und dadurch alle gewinnen können
und wirtschaft weil das auch ein thema
war im endeffekt fast 18 prozent unserer
gesellschaft haben eine behinderung das
ist eine wahnsinnige kundengruppe wenn
man also seine botschaften sein
unternehmen seine produkte auch
barrierefrei inklusiv denkt kann man
auch wirtschaftlich nur gewinnen die
vase wahnsinn es sprüht ist hier richtig
cool danke ich glaube ein wirklich
schöner podcast wir dürfen unsere
zuhörer oder wir dürfen nochmals
auffordern diesem podcast erstens zu
hören du hast ja diesen sport rapport
vielleicht erst ganz kurz was tust du
bei sport rapport beim sport rapport
interview das was du heute mit mir
gemacht hat da einfach spannende
persönlichkeiten aus dem herzzentrum
eben von diesen 450 sportlerinnen und
sportler wir wollen genau diese
geschichten hinter den menschen erzählen
zeigen was den menschen ausmacht was er
alles erlebt hat was wir alles mitnehmen
können und man findet den sport robot
auf allen gängigen plattformen apple
podcast dass spotify oder eben auch auf
youtube wo wir auch dann zu sehen sind
das heißt man sieht auch wirklich wer
redet da die ganze zeit und es ist
wirklich mal was anderes auf der anderen
seite zu stehen und auch antworten zu
denen nicht nur die fragen zu stellen
also dann gedacht haben alle 14 tage
gibt's diesen podcast zu hören wir
freuen uns dass ich heute bei dir zu
gast durfte ich nur dich interview
dürfte ich glaube es war eine co
moderation du mit mir ich mit dir
wirklich tolle inspirationen wirklich
ein dollar esprit den du da verbreitest
ich darf dir ganz ganz herzlich
gratulieren zu deiner seele
sportreporter viele gäste euch wünschen
die sich den podcast anhören
danke dass ich dafür durfte danke dass
ich dich interview dürfte
ein schönes leben danke und ich freue
mich auf viele die dann einschalten und
zu hören danke
[Musik]
[Applaus]